this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
okay so thank you very much for joining
us this evening I appreciate you all
coming out after working all day to
learn a little bit more about our
programs and how to engage with us
throughout the quarter my name is
Michelle Lucas and I'm the graduate
program manager here at the Stanford
center for professional development and
I'm pleased to be able to host you this
evening for this event we are recording
this session and we are streaming it
live so for those of you that are
accessing this online we are asking that
you submit questions comments feedback
through twitter at @steveadubato Center
for professional development we are also
going to talk about how to access videos
which I'm sure is going to be very
important to all of you and when you
guys start your classes next week they
begin on Monday you'll have less chasing
around trying to figure out how to
access the video content so we're going
to cover that in a pretty good detail
and we are also going to kind of go over
logistics summary of homework and exams
and who to contact if you guys need
anything during the quarter and also
share with you guys some resources that
will help you throughout the quarter so
we'll go ahead and get started so
stanford university opened here open the
doors for education in 1891 about 120
years ago it was founded in memory of
leland jr who was leland and james
Danford only son he died of typhoid
fever when he was 15 years old and so
they opened this university in his
memory and they had made a decision very
shortly after he passed that because
they wouldn't be able to do anything for
their own son they wanted to be able to
use their wealth to help other people's
children
that was the inspiration for this for
this university from the time that it
opened its doors Stanford University was
very untraditional it was co-educational
it was nondenominational and it also was
committed to providing a practical
education they wanted to produce useful
and cultured citizens so that differed
from a lot of the other universities
private universities at that time there
are seven schools and the schools really
focus on a multidisciplinary approach to
education they are collaborative across
schools within the departments and we
also have a lot of collaboration with
industry as well you can see the numbers
here of students and the one thing that
I would want to point out is that there
is approximately a 5.92 one student
faculty ratio which is unusual and we
have 5,000 plus sponsored research
projects here at Stanford and we have a
lot of initiatives on human health the
environment sustainability and three of
our school of engineering departments
are ranked number one by the National
Research Council the school of
engineering specifically it's one of the
top engineering schools at top
university we're located here in Silicon
Valley which is kind of the heart of
innovation here in the Bay Area lots of
entrepreneurs here world-class research
facilities there are again like I had
referenced in the last slide we have
five thousand plus you know projects
that are here research that are that's
going on on campus and so we have some
great labs with state-of-the-art
equipment here there is a large alumni
network which hopefully many of you will
be affiliated with when you guys have
finished up your programs here and we
have been pioneering industry education
for quite a long time I don't know how
many of you are aware of this but the
Stanford center for professional
development actually started out over 50
years ago with Hewlett and Packard and
Fred Terman who was the Dean of the
School of Engineering at that time and
they wanted to be able to offer
education to their engineers and there
there there you know leaders to be able
to continue and stay at the top of their
at their top of their industry so they
were able to facilitate a part-time
master's degree where the students would
come here to campus take classes while
they were able to maintain the career
the number of years later they were able
to broadcast the classes on a television
network and then about 12 years ago now
we started doing online education so
it's evolved over time but we've been
doing education for industry for a very
long time so the Stanford center for
professional development is really we
consider ourselves a bridge between the
research and the curriculum here at
Stanford University and Industry we have
two veins of our portfolio one of them
is the academic programs which you folks
are enrolled in participating in and we
also have professional programs as well
in topics such as strategic decision and
risk management advanced project
management IT benchmarking
entrepreneurship and innovation so there
are also the professional education for
folks that really perhaps aren't
interested in the academic credit but
want to be able to learn new skills that
they can apply immediately and they're
in their jobs so this is actually one of
our students I usually like to try to
highlight one of our participants in our
sessions here this is brett long brett
actually came to the Stanford center for
professional development through a
partnership that stanford university has
at the National University of Singapore
he came here in a coterminal program and
he
earned his bachelor's degree at nus
National University of Singapore and
mechanical engineering came back to
Stanford University and actually
finished up his master's degree here he
then went into the workforce and when he
was starting to work on some teams he
decided that he needed a little bit more
tooling to be able to do his job well
and so he participated in a professional
certificate program the Stanford a
strategic decision risk program I
learned a lot of tools that he was able
to take back into his career and get the
eyes get the attention of his management
he wanted to actually start to run with
that level of his group and wanted to be
more involved in the direction and
steering the teams that he was working
with so he participated in the
professional education certificate the
advanced project management when he
completed that he decided to undertake
master's degree in management science
and engineering and he did it through
the honors Cooperative Program which is
the part-time distance learning master's
degree so he really embodies what we try
to promote here which is lifelong
learning that you will be at different
stages in your career over your life and
and there's always going to be used for
education and knowledge on how to have
to do things differently and more
efficiently and and stay state that you
know leading edge of your career so
these are some of the partner companies
that we have memberships with I'm sure
that they many of them are familiar to
you and so we have I would say honor
about 300 325 companies that we have
memberships with and so these students
that are affiliated with these companies
are able to participate in the master's
degree program which requires that
company membership so this gives you an
idea of some of the companies that we
work with so to get a little bit more
detailed about our graduate portfolio
there are several different ways that
you can engage
the first one is through individual
courses and we call that the non degree
option and you can enroll in a course
for credit you can take classes with
online delivery and 18 units taken
through the non degree option program
can be transferred into a master's
degree program should you apply to the
department and are admitted so
participation in the non degree option
actually the students watch the videos
they do all of the same assignments take
the same exams they are they have the
same expectation and they earn real
stanford graduate credit so it's a great
opportunity for student for folks to
engage with stanford content here on
campus that is happening in the
classroom for students that have a topic
area that is of interest to them we have
graduate certificates which is the focus
guided curriculum within the School of
Engineering the departments that are
affiliated with our Center three to five
courses and you leave with a credential
from Stanford that you're certified in
that topic and again those credits roll
over into a masters of your program the
next level is the honors cooperative
program which is of master's degree
program here at Stanford is the same
master's degree that students take here
on campus when they are residential
students this just allows people to take
the degree at a part-time part-time
basis so they can maintain their careers
while they are taking Stanford classes
and earning their degree the one of the
benefits about the honors cooperative
program is that you can take the courses
online if your remote or you can come to
campus here and take classes you know
sit in the classroom and participate so
that's a great benefit for those of you
that are that are pursuing your degree
and the least committed program in this
which is just for people that maybe they
have a master's already or perhaps a PhD
but they just want to hear about what's
happening today and what's what's being
taught in that topic now we have an
audit program where you can audit of
course you get access to the video
and you can you know watch them 24 hours
a day seven days a week for the duration
of the quarter but you don't have the
you know the same expectation with the
homework and the exams there's no credit
there's no grade so there's no pressure
you just get to be able to you know
absorb the content that the faculty is
teaching in the classroom does anybody
have any questions about the different
levels of engagement here yes except
people in the honours club program all
your love or is it only involved so it
really depends on the department the
question is do we accept people in the
honors cooperative program to be able to
start all year and the answer is it
depends on the department there are some
departments that have a rolling
admissions where you can you can be
offered admission and start any given
quarter and there are some that they
just have an autumn we do have that
information on our website and you can
also find on the graduate admissions
website or Stanford University but the
admissions are also we don't actually
admit anyone but the grad admissions
department would go ahead and make those
decisions anybody else yes time limit
within the Juniper gate their forces to
be able to transfer towards and less
destiny it's a very good question the
question was is there a time limit that
you'd have to be able to take courses
through the non degree option and then
transfer those units over to the
master's program the honors cooperative
program and the answer is no the the
units that you take and the nandu option
program do not expire they will go ahead
and roll over into the degree the
department and your faculty advisor if
you're admitted into the degree program
would go ahead and make a decision with
you on what courses would be applicable
to what areas but no the units do not
expire okay so this is just a little bit
of a kind of a mapping system so you can
see how these different students engage
and where they where they find the
information that they need to be able to
enroll look at grades pay their tuition
and so you can see that for the audit
and do an HCP students to the course
selection you would go ahead and look at
the SCPD website for the honors
cooperative students that are here local
in the bay area and can come to campus
and you can go ahead and look at any of
the courses on the Stanford bulletin or
the access system and you can enroll in
any of those courses because you'll be
coming to campus but if you are remote
and you need to be able to access online
courses you're going to want to make a
point of looking at the SCPD website for
your selection of courses that are going
to be taken and the registration through
the SCPD website for the audit and
non-degree option honors cooperative
students actually enroll directly
through the access system and then we
will go ahead and take those lists the
study lists for our students and we'll
go ahead and enter those on the back end
of our system so you don't have to
enroll in both places and then again
like the the payment is through SCPD the
department approval when you're in the
honors cooperative program you're
approved by the Department for admission
to the degree and so you will work with
your faculty advisor to determine your
course path to be able to earn your
degree the non degree option you are
approved on a course by course basis by
the department however we are starting a
new process where we will be working
with the departments to have folks that
are interested in a specific graduate
certificate if they indicate that
they're intending to pursue a
certificate then we will go ahead and
work with the department's to be able to
kind of get a an overall approval of the
courses and as long as they it's a
performance based program and as long as
you maintain the the GPA to be able to
continue on then you will go ahead and
just be able to be approved by
certificate and then the the auditors
they aren't taking it for credit and
there's no interaction with the teaching
team so the department's don't need to
approve that process we can just go
ahead and process the audit enrollment
the videos which I'll go over in more
detail in a moment but the videos can be
accessed in your my Stanford connection
account on the SCPD website so that's
where you will go ahead and login to be
able to view the lectures each week and
then the grades and evaluations and
transcripts those are located in the
Stanford University
the system of record access and it's a
portal where lots of student information
and course information is contained
you're going to want to go ahead and
make sure that you check your grades
there because we do not store grades in
our system so to access the videos like
I just said a moment ago you would go
ahead and go to the SCPD website SCPD
stanford edu and then you'll login to
your my Stanford connection account some
of you I know that there are times that
we get questions about you know why if
it's online do you guys have the day and
the time posted on the on the course
page if I'm accessing it online why does
it matter and the answer is that the
videos are posted online within two
hours of the completion of class here on
campus and so we put that there as a
reference for you guys to know that you
know if you guys wanted to watch the
video at your lunchtime in your office
you know that's when you can expect it
to be there so we do post the videos
pretty quickly it's usually less than
two hours but we like to give ourselves
at that time frame so you guys have a
reasonable expectation so I'm going to
kind of just walk through very quickly
the next two slides because this is just
a quick graphical display of how to get
connected to your video so you'll go
ahead and go into the my Stanford
connection tab on our website and once
you're there on our site this is the
page that you'll see and you would just
click on the link my course records
which will take you to this page and
you'll have the enrolled courses which
are the courses that you're currently
participating in when you click on that
link under my enrolled courses it'll
take you to the video page for the
course and you can see that we do offer
the delivery in Windows Media Player or
Silverlight so you can choose whichever
of those platforms works best for you
and then you can go ahead and click on
that link that little icon there and the
videos will come up so once you click on
that this is what the user interface
looks like so you can see how the videos
appear when you are on the video page
and we do have a tab for notes and for
the lectures and the lectures stack up
in chronological order so that you can
go ahead and select the course of the
lecture by date if you guys are going
back to review
something or you know so that you know
how they will appear if the course has
problem or review sessions we try to
capture those in our classrooms and put
those online as well so that any kind of
additional sessions that are provided to
the students here on campus that will be
used to enhance the the lectures we try
to make sure that you all have access to
those as well so and those will be
included as extra session or problem
sessions you guys should be able to
identify those as being different than
the actual lecture yes those it is and
watch them offline so the question is is
there an ability to download the
lectures and watch them offline and the
answer is not in our current model we
are actually working to develop a
digital rights management platform that
we can go ahead and allow that to happen
but as of today it's it's not something
that we deliver widely to our courses we
have done a few pilots over the quarters
to be able to and we pick a you know a
selection of courses three four five
courses and we have piloted different
technologies that that will allow that
and they have been successful but we
have a little bit more work to do before
we deploy it to all of our courses so it
is something that will be available
going forward but we don't have a we
don't have a drop date on that yet so
when you are in the lecture page you'll
note note asst here at the bottom of the
of the page there is a link to create a
note if you wanted to say perhaps you're
watching the video and the faculty will
say something like this is going to be
on your final you can click on that link
and it opens up a window like this that
you can type in a note and you can I
mean you can you know whatever it is
that you want to remember about that and
you can then push submit and it will
appear like this within you know the
lecture so that you can go back and
review that when you're getting you know
preparing for your midterm
final exam you can also make the notes
so that they are private or you can
share them with other people that are in
the class online as well and for any
kind of technical issues that come up
during the quarter if you're having a
problem connecting to the course if
there's anything that prevents you from
from viewing the videos please don't
wait to tell us we really encourage you
to let us know right away because a lot
of this stuff can be you know figured
out very very quickly and get you back
up and running and make sure that you
don't have any issues we don't want you
guys to lose valuable time trying to
figure out what might be going on so
please be sure to contact our support
our tech support line if you guys have
any questions or any issues we have
folks that are kind of monitoring that
email and that phone line I don't know
if I go as far as say 24 hours a day 7
days a week but it's a it's pretty
consistent you'll get a response right
away rather than going to the faculty or
the teaching teams who then have to
contact us and it just slows you down so
we want to make sure that we get a quick
response to any issues that come up with
your video so one of the things that you
will learn if you haven't already but
when you start the class and you have
your first video the faculty will most
courses have a course webpage the
faculty will go ahead and refer to the
webpage so that you guys are able to you
know log into that it's often times
they'll have those on courseware or
course works or sometimes they're using
Coursera now Piazza there's lots of
different platforms that the faculty use
here and essentially you'll use your
student ID which I hope that all of you
guys have by this point or will be
getting very soon you'll use that to
authenticate through the university
system access the course webpage and
they have a lot of information there
about like they'll have the syllabus for
the course they'll have the teaching
assistants names emails contact
information phone numbers they'll have
office hours
a lot of the assignments are posted on
these sites so that's how you'll access
the assignments so the course website
will be provided on the first day of
class if you don't have it already some
of the faculty and the teaching teams
are really proactive and they start
setting these things up right away they
pull their class list from access and
they email everybody before classes
starts so some of you may already know
about this but if not not to worry you
will definitely get that the first day
of class and then you can go ahead and
make sure that you are able to find out
all of this information that's here so
one of the things that we like to
emphasize also as deadlines because we
appreciate that you guys are a busy busy
group of people you guys are juggling
your jobs and then classes and you may
have families and lots of other things
that are going on in your lives so we
really try to make a point of
emphasizing that you need to pay
attention to the deadlines the first day
of instruction so for any of you that
have it that don't know that already
it's going to be on Monday the 24th so
just a few days from now the date to
drop courses there's a date that you can
drop the course where you get a refund
and then after that date you can still
withdraw or take an incomplete but you
can't drop and get a refund so for those
of you that have a tuition benefit with
your employer and you guys need to make
sure that there's a refund you need to
pay attention to that date as well which
i believe is October twelfth not
positive but i'm pretty sure it's
october 12 then the withdrawal date same
thing it's a little bit further on in
the quarter the assignments and exams
that's something that i really want to
make sure that i emphasize as well is
that the faculty and the teaching teams
are integrating the online students with
their on-campus class and so there are
faculty that are very understanding that
will give you a little bit of leeway if
you have a trip and you're going to be
gone the day that something is due and
you need to turn it in the following day
or the day before before you travel and
we would encourage you to work with the
faculty if you have something like that
to comes up that said the faculty all
know that SCPD students are expected to
meet the same deadlines for their
assignments and exams as the on-campus
students so you may have one that that
says that they just can't shift it
because maybe it puts a monkey wrench
into their teaching teams grading
process but something if something comes
up I would say by and large the faculty
are pretty pretty helpful and try to
take things into consideration but don't
bank on that make sure that you reach
out to them as early as you know that
there may be a conflict talk to them
about it and they'll go ahead and let us
know if they be given use any kind of
consideration but but I would say
overall you want to try to make sure
that you can hit the deadlines for
assignments projects and exams and then
if you guys are looking for the final
exams dates that's something else that
will also be on the course webpage I
know that some of you have you know
business trips that you might need to
take and you don't want to miss the exam
so if you guys are planning something
and need to be able to have the final
exam date you should check on the course
website so that you can know early and
either make arrangements or you know
know if it's not going to be compatible
with your with your work schedule and i
will say that travel and workload is not
a reason to miss a deadline you want to
try to again always hit those hit those
deadlines to stay aligned with the class
on campus so for submitting assignments
we actually have a department within our
organization it's our distribution
department and they are phenomenal at
kind of managing the the the process of
getting assignments from our students
getting them to the faculty getting them
back from the faculty and back to our
students graded but so if you're
submitting the assignments to SCPD you
would want to go ahead and make sure
that so you can submit them by email or
by fax with this information here but
you also want to make sure that you have
your name the course how many pages the
page numbers on the page so that we know
that we have the entire assignment when
we receive it and we go ahead and
deliver it to the faculty we do when we
receive your assignments we do date and
time stamp them so that we have a record
of that one
the things that I'll also point out is
that the faculty a lot of them like to
kind of cut the middleman and just have
everything sent to them directly it's
easier we definitely don't want to get
in the way of what the faculty would
like to have happen so if they tell you
that they want you to submit your
assignment to them please submit them to
your faculty or the teaching team
directly but if you could also if you're
emailing it to them if you could copy
the SCPD distribution email on to that
submission the reason I say that is
because in this world of electronic
processes you know the lots of things
can happen and we don't want your grade
or your assignment to be depending on
whether something was received by the
teaching team so we have a system of
record that we can log the information
so if they can't find it or don't have
it it doesn't transfer it doesn't get
through we can give a backup and we can
also show the faculty that yes you did
submit it within the time frame that you
were allowed so please make sure that
you do copy us if you do submit it to
the faculty directly yes you have access
to these plates the slides so we're
actually taping this and we're going to
go ahead and put the whole presentation
online and all of this information is on
our website you can certainly find it
definitely so also if there's a missing
assignment if the faculty happens to
tell you hey what's going on we didn't
get your assignment let us know right
away and we'll go ahead and look into
our records and make sure that we can
either find it and get it to the faculty
right away maybe we can let them know a
date that we delivered it and so they
can they can go ahead and look in their
files and see if they've gotten it and
maybe got you know shuffled in with
other papers so please let us know if
there's any kind of a question about an
assignment not being received or not
showing up somebody didn't get it and
also if you haven't gotten your
assignments back graded and you know
that you know they've been distributed
by the faculty of the teaching team
please let us know and we'll make sure
that we kind of hunt those down and get
those back to that yes you don't ask for
like a student ID or like
suad on the submit assignments I mean
haven't you guys have problems named so
the question was that why don't we ask
for a su net ID or a su ID when people
are submitting assignments so that we
can make sure we have a tracking system
there and so that's why we say that we
want the course number maybe if we if we
come across a situation where we have
two people with the same name in the
same course we might start scratching
our head and thinking about how to get
around that but at this point we it
hasn't been a problem but it's a good
point you never know but but if you
could at least put this kind of this
information on it and if you want to put
your su ID or your soo net you're
welcome to do that too good question so
the question is once you submit your
assignment to us either an email or
submit it to us by facts which I think
most people use email these days what
happens then so the process is once we
receive your emailed assignment or if
you fax us your assignment once we've
received it we will go ahead and print
it out we've time and date the date and
time stamp it and then we have several
runs a day that our distribution team
makes out to the different departments
and we have bins in each department
where we leave homework and assignments
projects that are submitted and the
teaching team know where these bins are
they go and they pull all of the
information out they grade them with the
rest of the assignments and then when
they're done they put them back in the
bin we take them back we again we make
several runs on this route every day so
we do you know runs where we drop them
off we go back later on the day we pick
things up and then once we get them back
then we'll go ahead and scan them in a
PDF and we'll go ahead and email you
back the graded assignment so when would
you start expecting something's not
right a lot of times the course
instructor will indicate when something
has been returned if something has been
graded and sent back they'll usually
mention it maybe it
beginning of the class that you know
we've you know distributed the
assignments that were turned in last
week and they're graded so make sure you
look for them because the students here
on campus oftentimes will pick them up
there in class or maybe go to another
bin in the same department and pick up
the on-campus submissions so if you if
you do hear that they have graded and
sent them back and you haven't gotten
yours then you definitely should go
ahead and let us know and we'll see if
we've gotten them back yet for the class
and if you haven't heard anything back
and you guys are looking at you know on
the syllabus if you guys have another
assignment that's coming up in a few
days and you want to get that feedback
because it might you know determine how
you do things for that next assignment
please don't hesitate please please
contact us and let us know and we'll
make sure that we get on it immediately
okay so exams so I will let you know
that many of you have probably already
done this but so if you're taking a
course through SCPD every student taking
the course for credit antegrade has to
assign an exam monitor this monitor will
Proctor their exams during the court of
the midterm if there is a midterm and a
final exam we do this because the
Western Association of schools and
colleges requires that we you know
ensure that the exam is being taken
according to the guidelines that the
students here on campus are taking them
that they're you know within the the
guidelines that the instructor as far as
timing and tools or resources that are
able to be used so we do have everyone
assign an exam monitor at the start of
the quarter we will go ahead and send
you an email probably within the first i
would say week or ten days of the
quarter with a link where you can
designate someone that will go ahead and
and be on your account you can do it by
quarter you can do it by academic year
but we will go ahead and then send the
exam to that person who will go ahead
and administer them for you the exam
monitor does not need to be in the room
with you with a stopwatch making sure
you take the test
within a lot of time they'll receive the
exam they will go ahead and have a quiet
place for you to take it and they'll go
ahead and give it to you to take and
they'll let you know what materials are
allowed to be used in that session and
then when it's finished you will go
ahead and give your exam to that person
and they will receive it sign off on it
that it was taken according to the
teaching team guidelines and they will
return it to us the exam monitor is
usually an HR manager or a direct
supervisor if you don't if you work for
yourself and you don't have a manager or
an HR person that you can work with on
this then you can do it at another
institution you can do it at a local
library so there are definitely options
for those of you who don't have someone
within their company that can be a
proctor for them we do contact the exam
monitors and make sure that they
understand the responsibilities that are
associated with being in that role we
also make sure that they understand the
Stanford honor code so that so that they
know what they're signing up for and
also an exam monitor cannot be your
spouse your neighbor your mom you need
to make sure that it's somebody that
doesn't have a personal relationship
with you so when we contact them and ask
them what the relationship is to you
please don't submit your mom your
neighbor or your wife so again the exam
process we you know send the exam
monitors the exams if you have travel
business travel and your exam monitor is
going to change please let us know as
soon as you have that information it's
not a small task to be able to change
someone's exam monitor because we need
to change in our system we need to make
sure that we have confirmed that they
are an appropriate substitution so it is
a little bit of a process and we want to
make sure that we have time to do that
and we will not send out an exam to
anyone that does not have an exam on it
or pointed yes so if I'm coming here to
take the midterm
in the final of Louisville need an exam
oh so the question is if I'm coming to
campus to take the exams midterm or
final do I still need an exam honor the
answer I'm sorry is yes and the reason
is because to meet the WASC guidelines
for our accreditation we have to have an
exam monitor on file for each student
that's taking a course for credit if we
don't have that person on file you never
know you might be coming to campus and
you get a flat tire and you're stuck in
the freeway and so you have the tow
truck take you back to work and and we
want to make sure that if it as long as
we have somebody on file we're going to
send you your exam and make sure that
you can take it so things come up that
are unexpected and we just want to make
sure that you are going to be able to
take your exam regardless of the
circumstances so we do ask everybody to
cut to submit that yes we have to take
the exam after being sent to the exam
are so the exam guidelines are going to
be clarified to you by the exam or by
Sigma by the course instructor they'll
let you know how all the details about
how you're going to be able to take the
exam and typically we will send the exam
to the exam monitors the morning of the
exams going to be given or perhaps the
evening before so that they have it and
they're ready to give it to you when
you're when you're going to start taking
it some faculties say go ahead and send
it out early and it's you know they have
you know an undefined period of time
maybe a you know it's an overnight to
the exam sometime some courses give you
a week to take it so it really depends
on what the course instructor determines
of the guidelines and we make sure that
the exam monitors have them in advance
of that time either the evening before
or that morning first thing yes a cup
exam monitor and the event or primary is
not available very good question a
question was if folks can designate a
backup monitor in case their primary
monitor is not available and the answer
is yes we actually do ask for that we
asked for primary monitor and a backup
monitor so that we we have that on file
and if you are able to go ahead and
submit both it makes it a lot easier
things change then we don't have to
assign somebody and go through that hole
as we've already done it for both I exam
one had one question that just came
through can distance learning students
take exams on Stanford campus so the
answer is yes they can if the students
are within usually a 25 30 mile distance
of the campus some of the faculty will
actually expect the students to come to
campus they they want you in the
classroom taking the taking the exam
with the on-campus students whenever
possible obviously if you're not close
and it's not possible then yes you can
definitely take it online but but
absolutely if you're able to come to
campus we would definitely welcome you
yes turn examine can forest and what
should be pointed to do these case if
you're coming to campus yes I then let
us know that you're going to come to
campus and we will not send out an exam
to your monitor unless we hear that you
didn't make it and that you need us to
but yeah we we will not send it out if
you let us know that you're going to be
here on campus and I thought I saw
another question out here somewhere I'm
saying a question okay okay excellent
yes right so the not the question was
about the non degree option students and
access to the course and the non degree
option students are expected to access
the course through online delivery only
and the students that are in the honors
Cooperative Program have the choice of
either consuming it online or coming to
campus for the course and the reason is
I'll be very upfront with you is that we
have a very limited number of classrooms
here on campus class sizes are
increasing and there is just a lack of
seats and so we can't displace
degree-seeking students by inviting
non-degree students to the campus so
there may be classes that are online and
you see that there's a lot of empty
seats and you know if your local in your
clothes and
talk to faculty it may be fine for you
to drop in and sit in on a class once in
a while but we just don't we don't want
it to be a regular thing because there
will be times where it's it's just not
feasible in the classroom and so we try
to be respectful the students that are
pursuing a degree that need the course
to be able to complete their degree
program Oh question that huh so in order
to your home or online how do we I mean
that Monday Wednesday Friday you know
once in 2 p.m. whatever the class time
do we attended during that time or this
to our place if you're accessing the
content online the person was when do we
access the online content if it's monday
wednesday friday class 12 to 15 when can
we access that online the answer is that
the videos go up two hours later and so
you would be able to access it a couple
of hours after the class ends you'd be
looking at about 4 15 at the class ends
at 2 15 that well that's what time it
happens on campus and so when we post
that time then that's just for you as a
reference for when they'll be online yes
um how do we know where the class the
very classroom is so if you're an honors
cooperative students pursuing a master's
degree and you're going to be coming to
campus for classes the classroom you can
find it on the access system which is
where you enroll in the course anyways
so the classroom will be listed there
and then again the non degree option
students are not expected to come to
campus that's why we don't post the
classrooms on our website because the
students that are approved to be able to
attend on campus can access that
information on the access system Louise
do you use mr. Barton if we do decide to
Robin
as an idiot students are doing get a
no matter what's what city so
parking on campus is free from 4pm on
and if you are coming to campus to be
able to sit in our class or there's a
seminar you know some really wanted to
come here for office hours then there is
metered parking here on campus and you
can park in that parking there's I think
there's permits that you can buy like a
day permit depending on how long you're
going to be here on campus or it's it's
that it's free of charge after 4pm yes
to use a question is there like some
sort of system that tells you I wish
that this so the question was is there
any system that you can check and see if
there's availability in the parking lot
and I wish the answer was yes because
then a staff would probably look at it
when we drive into campus every morning
and see if we could get the best parking
lot spot but the answer is no you would
have to just you know use the searchable
campus map for the parking lots and then
go ahead and take a chance yes check the
course website or carefully listen to
lectures to know if there will be
homework or with over p email so the
question was do we have to check the
course website or watch the videos to be
able to know if there's homework and or
will it just be emailed it to you so the
answer is no it will not be emailed it
to not be emailed to you I'd be very
surprised if anybody emailed out the
homework assignments they have the
course websites where they post the
assignments they also referenced them in
the videos so the one thing that I would
make sure that I point out if I haven't
said it already is that when you are
taking the course for credit and a grade
keep up with the pace of the class you
don't want to wait a week or two to
watch the videos thinking oh there there
24 hours a day seven days a week I can
catch up you want to make sure that you
keep the pace of class I'm going to move
on and and I'll if there's more
questions on this topic let me know
after the so the Stanford honor code
when all of you created your account on
the SCPD website there's a few boxes at
the bottom that ref
one of them references the Stanford
honor code that you sign that you will
agree to adhere to this to boil it down
to the most simplistic of terms Stanford
honor code just essentially means do
your own work so for a more detailed
description of the honor code we have
flyers out here in the lobby this
evening that has some information about
it we have links on our website that you
can go to and read there's links on the
Stanford website but this was an honor
code that was actually developed by
Stanford students talking about the
expectation of them as students and of
Stanford University and its faculty but
it basically is just that everyone here
is going to do your own work you all got
admitted to these these courses so you
guys definitely are able to do this and
so we we have you sign that off and and
that's the expectation so if you have
any questions about it please feel free
to go to the Lincoln and read through it
on a more detailed note any other
policies or forms that you guys would
like to review that have to do with SCPD
engagement can be found in your my
Stanford connection account under the
forms and transcripts and policies so if
you have any questions about something
that's a good resource view as well so
the course evaluations we actually have
all of our students that are taking
courses for credit they're all uploaded
into the university system of record so
the university sends out course
evaluations every quarter to all
students that are enrolled in a course
for credit the they send them at the end
of the quarter and it's basically to
find out what how do you feel about the
class that you just completed how is the
teaching team in the instructor did you
feel that they were knowledgeable were
they prepared to teach the course we're
did with what did you think of the
materials that they use they want your
feedback it's very very important to
them in fact it's so important to them
that they will give you a they'll
release your grades about two weeks
earlier if you complete that survey so
for those of you that have
tuition reimbursement from your company
that's going to be very important I
should also point out that in the SCPD
website you are allowed to designate a
preferred email address but I should
make sure that I emphasize that the
Stanford survey is sent to your Stanford
email address so if you haven't gotten
it on your gmail account it's because
they don't send it there so you're sooo
net ID will also be your email address
and so that's where you want to go to
access this survey and if you complete
it then again your your grades will be
revealed to you sooner than they would
if you don't yes I'm sorry not
enormously it's not fun when it's
submitted it is anonymous because you
you go into a link it doesn't go
straight from your email address you go
into a link that just collects the
survey data you're welcome so then in
addition to the Stanford University
surveys we actually at SCPD have two
surveys that we send out to our students
as well one of them is at the time of
your enrollment we send you in your
receipt email a link to a survey that
takes just maybe a couple of minutes to
complete many of you have probably
already filled this out for the quarter
but it's really just we want to get
feedback on how the enrollment process
was for you we want to know if it was a
very easy or if there was anything that
was that was confusing or difficult or
didn't work the way that you expected it
to and we do actually read through the
responses and we are very very proactive
about trying to make sure that we
implement any changes that can make in a
more streamlined process for you so we
do ask that you if you do have a couple
of minutes we really like to hear your
feedback and then later on in the
corridor we actually send out a second
survey that is really more based on the
course we want to know from from our
students that are the Stanford
University surveys all the students in
the course taking the course
credit ours is specifically for the
distance learning student and we want to
know lots of the same information what
how was the course did it was it what
you expected did the did the teaching
team respond to your questions quickly
and accurately and were they helpful you
know how was your experience with the
online interface did you have any
problems with the videos we want to know
what your experience was as a distance
learning students so please do take the
time to complete those if you can
because it's really valuable to us and
we actually share the information that's
received which also is is anonymous but
we do share the information with our
entire organization and because we asked
a lot of questions about the technology
the course descriptions the the homework
and an assignment distribution process
you these surveys can be it can be a
changemaker so we definitely encourage
you to try to make sure that you submit
that information to us so this is the
homepage of our website and I just
wanted to point out like the the things
that you should really focus on when you
go there so the announcements anything
that's going to be coming up that's
important that we want to share with our
students we go ahead and post it there
on the announcements the my Stanford
connection is where you're going to log
in and get access to your videos and
your account the resources which I'll
show you that page in a moment has a lot
of information it has actually the video
recording of this orientation session
and we keep it there for the whole year
so you can access it if there's
something else that you wanted to kind
of refresh on we have a link to the
course advisors who work with SCPD who
are current graduate students that know
the faculty they know the department
administrators they know the courses in
the content and they can answer there
there a wealth of information to you and
so if you have questions about a course
or you know if your if your background
has prepared you well you know these
these folks are I can't say enough about
them they really work hard to make sure
that our students get very high touch
and have all the answers that they need
and we actually have some of our course
advisors here so I'll introduce them in
just a moment
but so that's located on the resources
we also have our graduate hand books
which have like the information very
detailed so that you can find out about
a lot of the data information that you
need to be successful and kind of know
what to expect for the honors
Cooperative Program there's one that's
for specifically for non degree option
students there's also one for auditing
students as well so those things are all
on the resources page the calendar as
well has a lot of dates that are going
to be coming up whether there's dates
that we don't do classes if there's a
you know an event than orientation event
here on campus so that's that's a good
resource as well a question from Twitter
lands for you can distance learning
students use on campus facilities for
example the swimming pool the gym the
library and so on ok so the SCPD
students who are participating in the
honors cooperative program they can
participate in and use the facilities
here on campus if they're here locally
the non-degree option students have
access to this a couple of the libraries
and some of the materials that are in
the libraries I don't know that they can
check them out but they can come here
and they can go ahead and use the
library facilities but the the entire
Stanford facilities as reserved as a
benefit that's reserved for the for the
degree students and so this is just a
quick shot of our calendar so you can
kind of see how things stack up and we
have things like the study list
deadlines and financial drop deadline
when the access system opens up for
winter enrollments for the honors
cooperative students so the withdrawal
deadline so this is a place that you
want to check if you don't have the you
know these things readily available or
at your fingertips from the course
website please by all means check our
website we have a lot of information
that would be applicable to all the
different categories of students here on
this page so this is the resources page
and we have a link that takes you to the
free course previews if you want to see
what
is going to be teaching you usually put
the first lecture from a course up on
our website on the course page so that
you can kind of test drive it and see
what you think it tells you what's going
to be covered it gives you a little bit
of an idea of what the user interface is
going to be like for that course it also
lets you see who the faculty is going to
be and kind of see what your take on
them and their teaching house styles are
so it's a really good place for you to
kind of see if a course might be a right
fit for you before you actually enroll
again we have the student orientation
video we have the grant graduate hint
student handbooks and then the course
advisors and if you click on that course
advisors it takes you to a page that has
email links to all the different course
advisors that work with us and so I know
that we have Luis kind of Shiro here in
the back of the room and he's our
management science and engineering and
statistics course advisor currently we
also have Steven Bagley here who's from
the biomedical informatics group and he
is the director of that program and he's
a great source of information we also
have chin hua zhuang who's here from the
mechanical engineering department and
she's of course advisor as well and we
have roshni Cooper who is the electrical
engineering course advisor and she's
there in the back of the class of their
hand up to and so these folks are going
to be here this evening in our reception
afterwards if you guys have questions
and you want to talk to them about it
please don't hesitate to go up and ask
them questions they're here to to help
you so the FERPA is the Family Education
rights and Privacy Act and essentially
this is another one of those boxes that
we have you initial at the bottom of
your account when you when you sign up
with a SCPD student account and
basically it says that we aren't going
to release your information to third
parties we will go ahead and release
your information to faculty and
university staff that need to know
beyond that we don't release it just
generally speaking to people on campus
here we can't make public or release
your information to anyone else
including your employers unless you give
us permission to do so something else
for those of you who are select company
pay we
you need your consent to release your
information to them even just the
tuition bill so just wanted to point
that out that we do not sell your
information or share it with anyone
outside of the teaching team and some
administrative staff here on the campus
that need to have that and just kind of
the little tail end here so if something
comes up I mean essentially the the big
theme contact us if something changes
you know with you getting started in the
course or you're having trouble getting
access to your soon at ID or your course
videos there's anything that comes up at
the beginning please contact us right
away we have a whole organization of
people that are here to help make this
an easier more positive experience and
so please use us in that way don't try
to you know figure things out or assume
that it'll get better if you just give
it more time don't wait things move very
very very quickly here on campus and so
we want to make sure you guys get
started off on the right foot and and
and start running with the class when it
when it happens here on campus if the
course isn't a good fit for you and you
realize that after watching the first
couple of videos you know pay attention
to the deadlines you can drop the course
and get your tuition refunded if you
determine that it's just not the right
fit and you may also be able to add into
another course that is may be better
suited if you're on the fence about
something if it's not too far into the
corridor maybe the before the end of the
first week we might be able to go ahead
and do that kind of a transfer so so
please you know be proactive and let us
know if you feel like it's just not
headed in the way that you thought it
might something comes up an emergency
contact us while there's limited
exceptions you know we can help you
determine if there's you know you know a
way that we can pause your enrollment
drop the course you know and do things
come up and I will definitely try to
work with you to be able to make sure
that we're taking care of whatever is
needed and that's my contact so if you
guys have any questions specifically
about the graduate programs the
portfolio of courses I invite you to
contact me email phone if you come down
to campus
and come into the office please feel
free to drop by and ask for me I'm here
all the time and I would love to be able
to meet you if I don't get a chance to
talk to you tonight and answer any
questions that I'm able to does anybody
else have any questions yes Stanford
time they'll address well ready find out
of it so you can use webmail which is in
the if you go to the Stanford main
website you can go into the alphabetical
listing and you can go into webmail and
you will be asked to authenticate you'll
use your soo net ID which is required to
access the course websites and all the
rest and your password and it will open
up an email box for you and so students
who are actively enrolled in a graduate
course for credit get access to a
Stanford email address and so you can
use that to communicate with classmates
with your teaching team if you don't
want to use your personal email and
that's where anything that's sent out by
the university or oftentimes from the
faculty and the teaching teams if
they're trying to send like a one email
out to all of the students on their
class list that's the email they send it
to so please make sure that you check
those emails and sometimes you can
actually change your preference on the
course webpage so that the teaching team
can email your individual email address
if that's something that you want let
them know and they can go ahead and let
you know how to do that yes Stanford
email forward to my personal email it's
a wonderful question I know it can
happen I don't know how to do it because
I've never had to do it personally but
the teaching team will definitely be
able to help you with that any other
questions yes in the state border into a
degree option taken off if you
transition into a degree can the non
degree option courses transfer into a
degree if you decide to participate in a
degree program later on absolutely
absolutely so not the professional
certificates but the graduate
certificate courses can absolutely up to
18 units is a non-degree option student
including the courses that are part of
certificate programs the graduate
certificate
programs can be rolled into a master's
degree anybody else yes a very good
question so he asked about office hours
and how students can engage with the
teaching team for office hours and the
answer is if you're local and you can
come here to campus the on the course
webpage they'll have their office hours
posted and if you're able to make it to
office hours you're absolutely welcome
to come and participate in those you
know it's a really great opportunity to
be able to meet with the teaching team
whether it's the TAS the teaching
assistants or the faculty or the
instructor and have a little bit more
time one-on-one with them or with a
small group where you can kind of
brainstorm and talk through issues in
the course and and you're definitely
welcome to if you're local and it's
convenient you know so some faculty and
teaching teams do use tools like live
meeting or WebEx or link to and so
there's as you've probably read in the
news and on the Stanford website there's
a lot of interactivity happening right
now on campus some of them are testing
that kind of platform out with their
office hours or their you know review
sessions others are doing it for their
classes so it really kind of depends on
on the faculty teaching the course and
if they are willing to use something
that's interactive like that and some
are I'll take one last question and then
we're going to have a reception out here
that we can answer more questions
throughout yes against program is
considered a nun degree that's correct
so the graduate certificates are
comprised of non degree option courses
they're the same courses that happen on
campus they're all the same courses the
non it's just the way that you enroll in
them and so the courses that are in
certificates are graduate courses
there's a collection of them that you
can pursue to be able to get a
credential from Stanford in a
specialized area and you can also roll
those courses over into a degree if you
decide to pursue a degree and you're
admitted by the department okay so I'm
going to go ahead and and end the
session here we have some food and
drinks out in the lobby and there's
going to be an opportune
review to network and talk to your your
your peers and classmates and some of
the course advisors I'll be here and
available as will much of the SCPD staff
so enjoy thank you again for coming and
we look forward to meeting and talking
with you in the reception
you